this man is a model and a very
successful one at that
Dale Keynes is not good-looking he has
no illusions about that but his well
special appearance gives him a
significant advantage over his flawless
rivals the same you can't tell that this
between these sword models so you're
saying to me look at them and you
instantly forget their faces that they
just like a blank canvas
Delphine's face was discovered by the
ugly models agency in London 20 years
ago he has had a very successful
modeling career representing major
labels such as Calvin Klein and Levi's
today he is 44 and lives in Berlin
I came to Berlin a few years ago and
trying to find work here in my field of
work there's an actor in a model I found
that there was no agency here in Germany
so I thought why not make one misfit
models is an agency for people who don't
meet the standard del Keens looks for
people of any body type race and age
tattoos disabilities and unusual
hairstyles are desired the only
requirement is the courage to be
different confidence is a big factor you
have to be happy in yourself and not
being scared of making yourself look
silly in front of the camera and being
comfortable with yourself and not
worrying about what sort of clothes
you're wearing because sometimes the
client wants to change your look into
something what they need these people
have that confidence
Rick Ellis from the US and his wife Jana
from Berlin Dale Keynes met them in a
Berlin nightclub
Edgar Schroeder is new to modeling he
came across misfit models by chance
undermining his own then my girlfriend
said I should apply because I have such
an unusual appearance we then met up in
a pop and they brought me along to a
shoot some shooting would come I never
thought about being a model till I met
del and he said I'd be good as a models
and as I do a little bit of theater and
an artist and so somehow it sort of
fitted he has already done print ads
and others for TV commercials for a
mobile phone company for example
so far the biggest contract for misfit
models has been a major car rental
company and the agency director tell
Keens even joined in the campaign was
the brainchild of this advertising agent
oliver Foss is one of the most creative
minds in Germany which gets him a lot of
attention he's had enough of ad
campaigns that feature beautiful women
and fancy cars to go in another
direction take someone who looks a lot
like all of us or maybe even a little
bit uglier a superlative but the other
way around and he's not alone other ad
agencies have now started to look at
unusual people the heavily tattooed
Danielle Baum dot appeared for Vivienne
Westwood at fashion shows in Milan and
Paris
germán Evelyn Hall is 68 and in demand
as a model thus superfecta sleep loss if
something's too perfect its lifeless
that's why Cindy Crawford's beauty spot
was so famous it was a flaw in a perfect
face it's the ideal combination having
something very beautiful
flaws make things interesting that's
something Dell Keynes had to learn over
the years today
he accepts himself as he is when I was
younger growing up people looking at me
laughing at me kids can be cruel but
who's having the last laugh now I'm
getting on with my life
Dale Keynes wants to help his models
achieve similar success and perhaps the
same self-confidence